[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le Président de la Rada
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs mes
chers collègues
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur du crâne en
France
la guerre
il y a un an presque jour pour jour
mes chers collègues
ce mot terrible
que l'on croyait banni du continent
européen
a résonné à nouveau en Europe
il ne s'agit pas d'une guerre
allégorique
de celle que l'on déclare de façon
parfois galvaudée dans une situation
d'adversité
il s'agit bien d'une guerre réelle d'une
guerre d'agression dans toute sa
brutalité
à vrai dire
la guerre n'était pas nouvelle
en ce 24 février 2022
votre peuple monsieur le Président de la
Rada
connaît la guerre depuis 2014
depuis l'agression de la Russie et
l'occupation d'une partie de l'Ukraine
9 années déjà même si ces derniers mois
furent d'une intensité rarement égalée
ce qui a changé
à partir du 24 février 2022 ce fut la
mobilisation inédite
des soutiens de l'Ukraine dans le monde
au sein de l'Union européenne et en
France depuis le sommet de l'État
jusqu'au simple citoyen sans oublier nos
collectivités territoriales
car il faut le reconnaître avec lucidité
en 2014 et dans les années qui suivirent
à l'exception des
Ukrainiens agressés et de quelques pays
européens
nous n'avions pas pris collectivement
vraiment la mesure de ce qui se
produisait sur le sol de l'Ukraine
et du danger représenté par
l'impérialisme russe
ce passé
fait des résolutions et désormais
derrière nous
votre cause est devenue la nôtre
parce que nous savons que l'Union
européenne ne sera pas en paix si la
Russie était victorieuse en Ukraine
nous n'avons qu'un objectif et un seul
que demain l'Ukraine soit libéré
la fermeture de l'engagement des pays
vous soutenant dans la France fait ses
preuves
la décision de livraison de char à
mx-10rc par notre pays comme celle
desquels on César puis la décision de
livraison de Charlots par d'autres États
ont constitué un tournant supplémentaire
dans la détermination collective à vous
soutenir
cet engagement est appelé à perdurer et
à ne pas faiblir
nous formons le vœu que la France dans
le cadre d'une aide militaire cohérente
concerté avec ses partenaires
continuent d'apporter une contribution
substantielle à votre système de défense
pour mieux protéger les populations
civiles et vous installations
stratégiques et vous aider à résister et
à reconquérir le territoire de l'Ukraine
internationalement reconnu
risque d'escalade
en tentant
cette interrogation légitime mais quelle
est l'alternative laissée par la Russie
ce n'est pas l'Ukraine qui nous
contraint à livrer toujours plus de
matériel c'est la poursuite de
l'agression et les exections Russes qui
nous imposent
la France et l'Union européenne
à la différence de l'Ukraine ne sont pas
en guerre
contre la Russie mais les autorités
russes sont bel et bien désignés comme
leur adversaire je cite l'Occident c'est
leur propre terme
dans ces circonstances
l'Ukraine doit non seulement être en
capacité de résister mais aussi de
prendre
l'avantage stratégique nous devons y
aider
monsieur le président
il y a 6 mois
en juillet 2022
vous m'avez accueilli ainsi qu'une
délégation de sénateurs dans l'enceinte
de la Rada
et vous m'avez donné l'occasion de
prononcer un discours en séance plénière
devant tous les parlementaires
peut-on se figurer un Parlement réuni
régulièrement mes chers collègues cela
menace permanente des alertes à
l'approche de missile destructeur
quel est le quotidien de nos collègues
parlementaires de la radar
en résistant
les Ukrainiens démontrent que les ruches
n'est pas la vertu des causes
désespérées
je souhaite mes chers collègues car cet
instant nous nous levions pour rendre
hommage au courage de nos collègues
parlementaires de la Rada à l'instar de
tous les ukrainiens et que nous les
applaudissions
[Applaudissements]
le 7 février
le Sénat des bettera d'un projet de
résolution en soutien à votre pays
qui dépasse les clivage politique et je
l'espère recueillera les plus larges
suffrages
le projet de résolution ne se contente
pas de répéter les résolutions
précédentes il fait chien le plan de P
présenté par le président zenenski lors
du sommet du G20 le 15 novembre 2022
souveraineté de l'Ukraine sur l'ensemble
de son territoire n'est pas négociable
la Crimée ou le don de basse n'ont
qu'une vocation être
ukrainien
surtout le projet de résolution du Sénat
ainsi sur l'impératif de justice afin
que les criminels qui au nom de la
Russie commettent des exactions et des
crimes de guerre qui persécutent qui
exécutent des civils sachent ils ne
bénéficieront d'aucune impunité parce
que l'impunité ouvre la voie au plus
grand crime et à la manipulation de
l'histoire en témoigne la négation
persistante par les autorités russes de
ce qui conviendrait de reconnaître comme
le génocide de Lolo de mort en 1932 et
monsieur le Président de la radar
ukrainienne mes chers collègues
sénateurs
le moment
que nous partageons aujourd'hui est
exceptionnel
sinon inédit si le président zeninski
s'est exprimé le 23 mars en
visioconférence devant le Parlement
français
jamais l'hémicides du Sénat a accueilli
le président du Parlement d'un pays en
guerre
et cela a fait même plus de 20 ans
c'était en 2003 qu'aucun président d'une
assemblée d'un pays étranger que s'est
exprimé à la tribune ce qui sera votre
cas dans quelques instants monsieur le
président
seul le président du bundeslament est la
présidente du Parlement européen ont eu
par le passé cette opportunité c'est
bien la dimension européenne qui est
conforme qui est en ce moment conféré à
cette tribune c'est dire le degré
d'amitié de confiance que le Sénat
témoigne à la radar et à son président
oui vraiment vive le crâne vive la
république et vive la France
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président de la Rada
dukraine
je vous souhaite la parole
aujourd'hui au Sénat de la République
française et de m'adresser à vous
de l'Ukraine en proie aux flamme
du Sénat par le rond aujourd'hui des
millions de criniens
qui vivent
une agression
la plus insensée et la plus terrible
depuis l'époque de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale
j'ai très envie que vous puissiez
entendre leur voix
épuisée
malheureusement
je voudrais que vous les voix de Mario
Paul et d'azophtales invaincus de dessin
si proche de français la voix de
bakmouth de Solidar au nom militaires
tiennent
jusqu'au bout de leur vie parce qu'ils
protègent leurs
voix vous entendrez ceux qui ont demandé
de l'aide dans l'immeuble détruit par le
missile russe dans la ville de napou ou
le 14 janvier 46
ukrainiens et une centaine a été blessé
je vous remercie encore une fois cher
Gérard et la délégation qui vous avez
présidée qui en juillet de l'année
dernière s'est rendu en Ukraine et et on
est revenu comme vous l'avez dit à
l'époque totalement transformée
différente c'est un acte de courage de
vrais amis
votre discours inspiré au parlement
ukrainien a été entendu par toutes les
graines
longtemps et de manière passionnée par
le député du Parlement par les
militaires offrons et partout ceux qui
aident l'armée
nous avons entendu l'esprit invaincu de
la France
l'esprit des Parisiens libres qui il y a
230 ans sont allés à l'assaut de la
Bastille oui aujourd'hui nous les
Ukrainiens nous prenons notre Bastille
aujourd'hui
est en train de se créer la grande
nation au crinienne qui dans cette lutte
épuisante est en train de se battre pour
sa liberté pour sa voix de développement
pour son avenir je suis ravie
aujourd'hui de
constater que dans cette
confrontationnelle le peuple français
est à nos côtés et je voudrais
à vous ces représentants exprimés toute
ma reconnaissance
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi on nous tue
uniquement parce que nous tout comme
vous nous aimons notre terre
toutes les armes disponibles
[Musique]
par l’obscurité en détruisant les
structures énergétiques critiques et les
infrastructures spéciales
de restaurer l'Empire russe ou bien
l'Union soviétique
du droit international et d'énormes de
coexistence pacifique nous sommes tués
sur son ordre par ce qu'il y a encore
nous jurer être nos frères
l'opération militaire spécial à
l'Ukraine
que la presse
une couverture cynique de l'invasion de
l'Occident qui ne pourrait être arrêtée
qu'en important la victoire sur cette
agresseur chers amis déposez les armes
n'est pas notre voie
est de répondre et riposter à
l'agresseur et défendre notre terre
l'Ukraine est devenu ce bouclier qui
protège l'Europe et l'ensemble du monde
civilisé
donne la mort et la destruction produit
des fake faisant reposer la culpabilité
de ses crimes sur l'Occident collectif
par conséquent n’essa donc pas à la
désinformation de Moscou qui a des
racines historiques profondes nous nous
souvenons très bien tous
des villages inexistants de Potemkine
et sont en plus tard les mêmes procédés
ont été utilisés
lorsqu'ils ont essayé de persuader le
monde entier
que les tragédie tel n'existe pas qu'il
s'agit du théâtre que ce sont des
acteurs
qui étaient en train de faire les images
nécessaires
de notre cas très éloquant des années 30
du siècle dernier lorsque Staline tuait
les Ukrainiens par la famille
parle de l'arrivée à l'Ukraine de
célèbre en politique français Édouard
Herriot
famine puisque son itinéraire avait été
établi de telle manière pour qu'il ne
voit que des villages et des colocosses
prospère nous pouvons vaincre
qu'ensemble
s'arrêtera pas à l'Ukraine mais
continuera à promouvoir
et peu importe comment ça sera fait
militairement idéologiquement
la bête se présente aujourd'hui comme
agneau mais aspire toujours à tuer et à
s'emparer de nouvelles territoires
chers amis un grand penseur français
René Descartes avait dit en son temps
que nous devons appeler les choses par
leur nom
sinon
on le fait on pourra éviter la moitié
des erreurs de l'humanité par conséquent
je m'adresse à vous en vous demandant
d'appeler les choses par leur nom nous
devons reconnaître la Fédération de
Russie comme état terroriste et je
demande le Sénat a soutenir cette
décision
[Musique]
déjà été adoptées par le Parlement
européen par l'Assemblée parlementaire
du Conseil de l'Europe et de l'OTAN par
le Parlement et le gouvernement d'autres
pays
je salue également votre solidarité dans
la question de création d'un tribunal
spécial afin de traduire devant la
justice tous ceux qui ont commis et
continuent à commettre des crimes de
guerre car seul l'impunité
l'absence de l'impunité comme principe
suprême de justice rendra impossible la
répétition de ces crimes à l'avenir donc
la Russie n'arrête pas son agression et
ne quitte pas un territoire ukrainien
elle n'a pas sa place ni aux côtés des
pays de grands set
ni parmi les pays de je vends
ni aux Jeux Olympiques
2024 à Paris
de l'agression la France est soutenue la
résolution de l'Assemblée générale de
l'ONU quand du mécanisme de compensation
des dommages causés à l'Ukraine je
voudrais vous remercier une nouvelle
fois pour votre leadership dans l'octroi
des armes à l'Ukraine qui nous permet de
nous défendre et par conséquent nous
aidera à vaincre
dans votre exemple beaucoup d'autres
pays du monde
nous aide et déjà nous obtiendrons
bientôt des chars si nécessaire à des
crèmes nous espérons sincèrement que la
France sera la première à donner à
l'Ukraine
ces avions modernes
j'ai un mix 10 RC ont déjà fait leur
preuve sur le champ de bataille
et parmi les militaires des forces
armées ukrainiennes qui nous aident à
contenir efficacement à l'ennemi en même
temps notre priorité reste la même ce
sont les avions les blindés lourds et
les moyens de défense entière il y a et
intimes nous devons obtenir une super
urité au sol et fermer le ciel au dessus
de le crème en tant que peuple pacifique
même dans cette situation d'agression
militaire nous pensons toujours à la
paix nous pensons à la pestables car
nous n'avons pas besoin de ce qui nous
appartient pas nous ne faisons que des
fois ce qui est à nous c'est pourquoi le
président de l'Ukraine a proposé au
monde la formule de paix composée de 10
points et qui ambitionne de mettre fin à
cette guerre chers collègues aidez-nous
à réaliser et à créer
une nouvelle structure puissante de
sécurité européenne et mondiale mais pas
au prix des reculades et des compromis
dont auront honte non
enfants et nos petits-enfants
nous avons besoin de garanties de
sécurité
solides
et à le temps de cette tribune du sauna
français je voudrais appeler l'Europe et
la communauté authentique a nous
accepter rapidement et sans hésitation
parmi ces membres nous accepter comme
une famille accepte reçoit un guerrier
qui revient à la maison après une guerre
terrible un guerrier qui a gagné qui a
protégé sa famille sa terre notre avenir
européen commun
le statut de candidat à à devenir membre
de l'Union européenne je rappellerai
quand mars de l'année dernière lors du
sommet de leader à Versailles c'est la
pression de la France qui a permis
d'infléchir la situation c'est produit 2
semaines après la dépôt de candidature
de l'ukrain à l'époque les heures de
lieu ont adopté les décisions de prendre
le crâne et de le faire de l'Ukraine
membre de l'UE quel que soit le
développement des événements comme a dit
en son temps en heure de Balzac qui
comme vous savez a trouvé son amour en
Ukraine pour
atteindre un objectif il faut tout
d'abord y aller
et nous y allons en tant que chef du
parlement ukrainien
je puis vous assurer que nous allons de
manière certaine vers notre objectif en
travers de manière efficace sur
l'adoption des décisions et des réformes
nécessaires des lois nous sont partis en
conscients que l'entrée dans
simple le président de l'écran le
Parlement le gouvernement font preuve de
manière constante de la tolérance zéro à
l'égard de la corruption et se battent
contre ce phénomène
bien que durant les quelques derniers
années il y a eu des
démissions et des arrestations des
fonctionnaires peu scrupuleux
aujourd'hui nous recevons de l'Ukraine
des signaux sur le fait que le front
anti corruption continue son travail
aujourd'hui il y a des perquisitions
auprès d'autres fonctionnaires
anciens exfoliaire aujourd'hui car la
société exige que chaque personne chaque
n'est toujours pas compris que le crâne
est un pays européen qui professe sa
démocratie et bien il doit emporter la
responsabilité juridique
se produit pour la première fois depuis
30 ans chers collègues nous sommes
intéressés à terminer le plus rapidement
possible cette recommandation
établie par la Commission européenne et
entamer les pour parler de notre
entreprise dans l'Union européenne je
suis persuadé que très rapidement
le résultat de notre travail commun sera
évident le crâne peut et doit avoir le
statut de membre ou par un tiers au sein
de l'Union européenne et cela doit être
fait de manière dynamique et efficace
nous comptons également sur le soutien
de la France amicale
pour atteindre l'entrée de l'Ukraine
dans le temps dans le contexte du sommet
de l'Alliance qui aura lieu le 11 12
juillet 2023 le crâne n'est pas resté en
dehors du contexte euro-atlantique
chers amis
accueillir en France peu de 100 000
citoyens ukrainiens
ce sont les futurs citoyens de l'Union
européenne je vous remercie
de votre solitude pour nos enfants qui
ont intégré vos écoles
leur mère qui s'occupent de ses enfants
et vous occupez d'elle votre propre
histoire a donné à nos peuples à nos
cultures plus d'une chance de nous
réunir cette chance a lieu également
aujourd'hui comme j'ai déjà évoqué dans
vos
amis il y a un phénomène historique qui
s'appelle Lolo de mort la famine suite à
s'agissements
criminel du gouvernement de Staline des
millions d'ukrainien ont péri et
aujourd'hui le signal de la part de la
France c'est de la reconnaissance du de
mort comme je ne cite du peuple
craignant sera extrêmement important
quand les événements de 1932 33 confirme
l'intention du pouvoir de Staline de
l'époque et de la Russie continuent
aujourd'hui au cours de l'histoire
moderne de détruire l'identité du crayon
je voudrais appeler tous les présents à
soutenir le projet de résolution de
reconnaissance de la famille 32 33 en
tant que je ne cible du peuple craignant
président de l'Assemblée parlementaire
de le temps et la présidente du groupe
d'amitié franc succès au Sénat madame
solo monsieur le Président en
s'adressant l'été dernier aux Ukrainiens
depuis la tribune du Parlement ukrainien
vous avez dit à très juste titre que
l'âme européenne est les idéaux sont
réalisés aujourd'hui par incarner
aujourd'hui par le peuple craignant
notre hymne national a une ligne
importante
nous donnerons notre âme et nos corps
pour notre liberté et nous prouverons
frères que nous sommes de la ligne
cosaque en effet la liberté et notre
idéal est la vie dans une grande et
libre famille européenne
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
atteindrons notre objectif sans aucun
doute nous gagnerons sans aucun doute
quand un vérité de notre côté il nous
rec sans aucun doute l'Ukraine libre et
indépendante n'avons pas le droit de
perdre notre chance historique
je vous remercie de votre attention
gloire à l'Ukraine et vive la France
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président je vais
maintenant suspendre notre séance elle
sera reprise à 15h15 précises pour les
questions au Gouvernement je vais
raccompagner maintenant notre hôte la
séance est suspendue
[Applaudissements]